we had a whole lot of mess some Hannah
and sirs
so many people stay like in the shallow
waters of life and shocking elimination
it sucks that he didn't get to see like
all of Sydney this is your bachelor
season 24 episode 6 second episode of
this two week episode recap grab your
glasses it's time for roses and rosy
hello again everybody it's still me
lauren zima boo what kind of look like
beyond saying this top okay I don't
really but there are bees you know I'm
saying so gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
so two episodes this week everyone what
did you think overall did you like all
the content was it too much content can
you ever get enough of The Bachelor let
me know in the comments below
hmm let's get to it cheers to a new week
okay everything put behind us and just
like Tammy we're gonna toast to a new
week we needed this didn't we care let's
move forward let's push on in this
moment seemingly encouraging drinking
these two episodes did really make me
reflect on the season it was so much and
as I'm looking around this table and
seeing Tammy make this toast I am
realizing that only three of these women
have not started sobbing and gotten into
fights with people
Kelly Madison and Natasha we cheers to
them
we learned this week that Peter loves
mess he loves women who are crying he
loves women who are struggling
remember he loved Hannah Brown who was a
self-proclaimed trainwreck of a mess
like Marie Kondo Peter whoever loves
mess I love this it's a balancing act
you know because we want the drama but
we don't want to be drained from it but
this moment of peace won't last long
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving and by that I mean McKenna starts
to talk finding out that the cocktail
party was cancelled it
just like upset me and I timed it
everybody not on this watch on my wrist
that doesn't exist but on my phone it
took exactly 15 seconds of talking for
McKenna to start crying I just did not
picture myself to be like feeling this
way I wrote down shouldn't McKenna just
self exit what did you guys think so
Peter and his scar arrived to do another
toast Cheers to continuing to look for
love I did this when I was just starting
to take you in the scenery you know look
for something to bring me joy and where
did I look and of course that was in the
class is what were they drinking they
all seemed to be drinking the same thing
and at first I thought oh is it a
margarita I left tequila but then I
thought no look into the local culture
and they are in Chile and I believe
needs to be pisco sours and I thought
let's get festive because is going
sideways everybody so we're gonna go
sideways for the first time ever on
roses and Rose a we are not drinking why
just like Peter we're freaking out just
like the ladies were being indecisive
you never know when we might drink next
time just kidding you guys we have a
bottle of real stay on standby always
yeah you scared us that wasn't a nice
thing to do
Nick one Jacy Chris Anne
[Music]
thank you you know guys I hate cooking
the best cooking that I do is mixing
drinks but I don't have I've never made
this before and I don't have any kind of
a recipe to follow there's ice in here
so you know ice we like cold stuff more
is more sure we looked it up I don't
have the recipe but I do have the
ingredients which is usually how I
operate
and it's pisco lime juice aromatic
bitters and egg whites I usually like
fresh lime juice but Christian didn't
get that she got that pre squeezed but
went ahead and got me the full eggs so
now I gotta get an egg wet out of this
which I've literally never done if
anyone has tips let me know in the
comments below okay so
maybe if I just crack it really just a
little crack on your slip away Pokemon
[Music]
see this is mess and Peter would like
this Peter likes mess I've learned this
episode much more chic yes oh my gosh
we're doing real things here today okay
all right and then it says to garnish
with an aromatic bitter nice no it's not
okay it's not my favorite color combo
not the chicest
but let's give it a try Oh one of my new
favorite cocktails great we needed some
fun we're gonna have a little fun with a
one on one Peter and Hannah and
everybody so of course they're dancing
and then they're smearing I believe it
to have been hotdogs mayonnaise all over
each other and Peter is talking about
how silly Hannah Anna's with this man is
by the goofiest oh here kind of gross
right I don't know Oh Peter lips mess
explains it we run into our regularly
scheduled hired elder couple who we have
every season they are brought on to
highlight all of the insecurities of the
current relationship situation so they
bring up how young Hannah Ann looks oh
thank you and are they really in love
mm-hmm wow this is
you should just toss it back always any
more time
this is the kind of mess I can get
behind mm-hmm if it's a mess in a glass
I say pass it over to me if it's a mess
in a glass I say don't kiss my just give
me the drink if it's a mess in a glass I
say oh that's got a little sass so of
course Peter starts to ask Hannah Ann
about her age now did you guys think
this was fair at the end of the day I
think Peters 27-23 so there's only a
4-year age gap between them but I will
say sometimes there's quite a different
life place gap between your early 20s
where Hannah Ann is and your late 20s
it's the difference between being kind
of fresh out of college and well into
your career another big one Ana and does
tell Peter she's never been in love
before I've never like truly been in
love but ultimately what was the most
concerning to me where Hannah Ann's
comments at dinner I was confused what
are your goals yeah career-wise Peter
asked to see Ann about her career goals
and she says she wants to keep modeling
I think but that she doesn't actually
see it as a job I mean it's not
necessarily a job and then instead of
addressing her career or family or
relationship goals she goes into what we
could loosely call an analogy she says
she says she wants to swim in the deep
waters let's go deep so that there
aren't any minnows for her to catch and
you'll only catch minnows in the shallow
and I'm thinking is she talking about
modeling a swimwear ultimately I think
she might have missed the ending where
she was supposed to circle back and
comment on catching big fish let's not
stay on a superficial basis he's just
like I told I'm so not about superficial
listen I'm happy I mean if we really
break it down this was Peters question
what are your goals
here's Hannah Ann's answer you'll only
catch minnows in the shallows what the
only saving grace was that Hannah Ann
talking about shallow waters took
to a certain place tell me something
Hannah do you wanna catch some minnows
or are you going deep baby tell me what
are your career goals
you don't know in the shallow just fall
into the deep water now trying to stay
above but you're drowning in hotdogs
mayonnaise now you're of the deep and
that's where you wanna be trying to
catch the big fish Hannah doesn't like
minnows and now we know but is Peter her
ultimate wish let me know in the
comments below okay
I lost my pages then we're still in this
conversation though and Peter asks about
her past relationships
Hannah Anne says she dated someone for
three and a half years for about three
and a half years from my home town but
wasn't in love it wasn't in love I mean
no Peter the follow-up question right
there would have been then why did you
date for three and a half years what did
you guys think I do understand that when
you're younger maybe at the time you
think you're in love but looking back
you realize you actually weren't I just
wanted more from Hannah Anne explain
that more did you say I love you to this
person what did you learn from the
relationship what did it tell you about
what you want to find allegedly earthy
excuse me for one second Peter leaves
and Hanna and cries why won't you try
that like it wasn't enough for Hanahan
to talk to Peter about a relationship
she needed to cry and then he's like
will you accept this rose I know I'm
starting to wonder if Peter has had such
a stable past with his beautiful family
that he is a caretaker and that he feels
best when he's taken care of a mess am I
getting too deep tell me what you think
guys there's two date card next up this
show is the gift that keeps on giving
and it's giving us a curveball there are
two date cards who will get them we'll
let you know after the break I'll still
be drinking this Anne's word back there
are two date cards
Victoria s I feel like we didn't get a
fair shot and Victoria F is already
getting that F in second one wow wow wow
this news brings us to checking my
imaginary watch I would say these 79th
time that McKenna has cried but it was a
landmark first time that I agreed with
her tears that would be frustrating
right if you hadn't had a one-on-one yet
and then somebody else got a second I
would say I have to leave I don't man
you don't like me right so you know what
drink for agreed with McKenna oh and
then I wrote down and drink for agreeing
with her even more because then McKenna
says maybe she should just leave maybe
it's time for me to leave then we've got
a group date and we love drama this
season so we're making a telenovela
Judy I actually thought this was a lot
of fun I mean I love the theater I love
a costume I love a character or so
really in my wheelhouse tell me what you
guys thought of this date I really
enjoyed Kelly she played the grandmother
and some women might freak out oh they
got a nun sexy character but Kelly
really dug in and made some incest jokes
I'm just gonna say incest is best mom
and she was having a good time and her
and Peter seemed to really be connected
mckenna got a little bit of an uplift
and that was nice
she had a moment with pedro as we're
calling him and i wrote down
cheers to McKenna she kind of took
advantage of this moment and got in a
little time with Peter she wasn't
letting everything get her down and in
fact Peter lifted her right up now
cheers for our imaginary counter yeah
Peter doesn't even need to kiss anybody
on a counter anymore he just creates 100
in there
interesting Peter likes mice and McKenna
was a maid and when she was a maid they
connected clean it up okay things take a
turn at the cocktail party peter is
telling Victoria P and he has felt
things drop off I think we both kind of
felt a little bit
they kind of like drop off oh my god her
response here she says and I quote I
hate that for you distracting I love it
Peter's telling her I'm not really sure
about my feelings for you anymore and
she doesn't say that hurts me or that
sucks she goes I hate that for you I
kind of loved her confidence level you
know she's telling him I'm so sorry
you're not into me
your loss are you like saying that you
don't want me to be here and things do
escalate quickly don't they I've
critiqued Peter for being a little bit
too indecisive and he was being
indecisive here just shrink as he's
being indecisive so like I'm not really
sure if I see you as I don't know if I
see you as my wife unclear but then
things get clearer because she leaves
can i watch
I'm not really sure what the turning
point was but I did appreciate that it
just ended I did not see that coming did
you Victoria P leaving I did say you
should have just sent her home with a
lab you know I think Peter knows on some
level but he doesn't go
you got a no and Pisco I might need more
this but I don't want to make one at one
point I was saying Victoria P for
Bachelorette but I'm not sure I'm there
now are you but Peter bounces back
quickly a little fun in festivity we see
Madison for the first time in about a
decade yes she's still on this show and
a Pisco for Madison she's in a good mood
I think Peter and Madison's connection
is strong you guys even though we didn't
see her much in last episode every time
we do see her he's happy she's an escape
and this time he took the time to write
out something really thoughtful for her
I wrote us another script a stage show
viola I need to talk to you
what is it bedroom you really hurt me it
is nice to be here with Madison at this
point she is literally the one and only
person in the house who hasn't cried
gotten in a fight with someone else
or come at Peter with critiques so this
moment is wonderful and sweet it's an
escape into a Chilean sunset or
something you can see with the passion
to lay the million chili enzymes mmm
Marcus Peters play was a bit unclear to
me but at the end of the day I enjoy the
theater I wrote down we are seeing
McKenna smile for literally the first
time ever but not for long everybody I
was shocked
what's next I didn't see it in the
script I didn't see it in act 3 I didn't
expect this character arc I'm not trying
to come up view I was just like getting
serious
taemi ghost totally over the edge should
you act like a child she does not take a
child Tammy I'm not talking to you pal
see this was nuts right and burnt embody
who Valeria's Tammy had said earlier in
the episode that she was going to
channel her telenovela character all
night long so she comes at mechana tells
her she's living in a fantasy world
living like this fantasy world tells her
she's not here to call her out I'm not
trying to come up you I was just like
which she is totally doing she was
coming at her so hard I honestly thought
she was joking for a second and that
she'd say McKenna I'm just kidding on
being my character but now Tammy has
taken her character on in a method kind
of a way McKenna I just really don't
think that you're there they've merged
into one but Tammy Weiner is gone she's
gone from spunky Tammy to stirring the
pot Tammy Tammy sitting us with whammies
we don't know this Tammy where'd you go
Tammy would you go as Peters mother
would say you bring her home
don't let her go home to us you break up
miss Tammy okay see you later so
rightfully so Madison gets the
group-date rose cheers to Madison she's
really mad at something this is almost
done I don't want it to be over
do you have the season to be over and
let me know in the comments below okay I
will say this we've had quite a lot of
drama lately but Peter is so deeply
invested and we're seeing such mess but
I do think the ending is gonna be wild
because his emotions are gonna be so
strong and these ladies cry so much I
think we're an act to here but but after
the intermission then we get one-on-one
number two with Victoria F and I don't
want to shock you but she says she's
nervous but what they're actually doing
is playing horse limbo I don't know I
didn't know what to call this they were
going under horses and then I literally
seriously truly and ultimately cannot
believe it they are dancing we just have
so much fun together
[Music]
they put of course things take a turn in
Victoria F is crying now I literally
wrote down idk I don't know why she's
crying I'm clear let me know if you know
something about like her walls probably
then being up they got to come down I
didn't know it was possible but we've
taken things to a new level of freaking
out for Victoria F we've had screaming
drooling I'm literally drooling I can't
like breathe thinking she's saying she's
possibly going to puke here tonight I
think I'm like a girl can't shake and
then Victoria says something so
important and Peter just blows right by
it you know why because it's a logical
solution and Peter Webber loves this
Victoria tells Peter that she wishes she
understood her own issues like I wish I
can play get to a point where I like I
knew my own issues so that you didn't
have to deal with him so that she could
deal with them and Peter wouldn't have
to generate I mean like maybe she needs
to address her growth on her own before
she can embark on a successful
relationship with another together
person that makes sense Victoria that's
the best thing you've said all season
but no Peters like but I want to handle
the mess and when you do is done right
now Peter even gives a 747 statement but
in a negative way he tells her that no
one has put him through this much grief
on the show nobody has been giving me
this much
it's like Greece and then he says will
you accept this rose
[Music]
I'm drowning in the mess Peter I'm
drowning but anyway so Peter gives
Victoria the rose and she's like oh cars
he cursed I mean back to whiplash just a
minute ago she was saying maybe she
should leave the show I don't know
McKenna and Tammy what now we have a
two-on-one with McKenna and Tammy
because Peter has said enough is enough
to that meet me at the cocktail party
before everyone else arrives enough is
enough
they're on the two-on-one but I wanted
to have fun so I was noticing all the
barrels I'm the date I'm kind of
wondering if there was wine on them
maybe there's pisco in them are their
pisco girls what's up in Chile hmm I
want to know your side of this Tammy's
reaching reaching for insults she
accuses McKenna of writing hashtags she
says things like it seems like it's the
McKenna show she's trying to create
hashtags for her brand we looked it up
McKenna has done things like hashtag 23
cuz that's her age which I feel she
wouldn't have pre-written in the house
that writes itself she points out them
and kind of packed her bags before the
group date bats didn't really bother me
what did you guys think I kind of felt
me kind of did that because she wasn't
sure how well things would go and she
was really feeling beaten down by the
whole process of Peter I didn't blame
her I truly feel bad for you Tammy's
accusations don't have much muster to me
at one point she accuses McKenna of
taking things too lightly she takes it
very lightly and I'm like Tammy all the
girl has done his crime that's the roads
you're gonna go down she's arguably the
most affected person here
Tammy starts saying she and Peter are
meant to be this was meant to be cuz I
truly believe that I felt like at this
point Tammy was going a little crazy
where's Madison I just want to live
inside the theater of the Chilean sunset
anyway Peter sent a me a flower you know
but I kind of think mechanic and Tammy
both should have gone home just to give
me kind of kind of handle all this we're
being told that all the drama is gone we
we've got the drama hopefully and then
we're at the cocktail party rose
ceremony and Peter and calcia found a
whole room full of barrels of wine so
god then at the rose ceremony don't
drink for every wine barrel you see so
the rose ceremony gets underway and it
feels a little crazy because with
everything that's gone on this week it
already seems like several women have
gone home and I'm kind of wondering who
is going to be sent on their merry way
from this rose ceremony McKenna is sent
home and I was shocked by this because
Peter why didn't she just send her home
with Tammy it's Victoria P and Aleya all
over again why did he just send us both
home but then I was really shocked
because Peter sent Oh Sydney Sydney
Sydney Sydney Sydney save me save me
save me why do I feel I'm expiring was
there poison in the pisco sour so anyway
um Peter said Sydney home and Peter said
Sydney was the best kisser in the group
be the best kisser shut up I was
Sydney was somebody who got a 747
statement what did you think after
sitting with some home guys nine company
with my hood up because I'm trying to
protect myself after five hours of The
Bachelor this week so many scandals so
much in the news and here to tell you
that I asked pilot Pete about it all in
a new interview
shameless plug yes we talked to Victoria
F send me the overall criticism that his
group of women are arguably the Caddy
isten most dramatic in bachelor history
yeah discussed his ending and so much
more a lot of its up now Aditi online
calm but even more going up next week
I'll keep you posted follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and right now I'm
just gonna shelter in place anyway we
have six women left now Hannah and
Madison Victoria
Natasha Kelsey and Kelly
Natasha hasn't even had a one-on-one
date yet which is a little crazy but
what's even crazier is how McKenna
exists you guys and she is powerful
then she's beautiful and take notes
[Music]
you mean McKenna that was powerful stuff
I'm gonna be starting my days very
differently now she is tough and she is
strong and she is powerful is beautiful
and knows what she deserves
okay here we go tell me what you guys
are predicting for the end of this
season six women remaining who will
Peter end up with if anyone at all well
he said in interviews is that he's happy
let me know in the comments below I love
you guys so much and if I'm being honest
after those five hours I feel I deserve
another pisco sour so I'm gonna go
[Applause]
you're up the deep end no you're not you
are a sane person making pisco sours I
gotta go home because I'm tired The
Bachelor was five hours
[Applause]
by
[Music]